ora Boas pessoal bem-vindos a mais um
vídeo e hoje vou ensinar como fazer uma
minha estrelinha de papel para vocês
enfeitarem a vossa árvore é mas o Natal
já não passou então foi o seguinte eu
gravei este vídeo há muito tempo atrás
só que entretanto eu fiquei muito doente
fiquei uma semana de cama e não deu para
editar o vídeo a tempo como eu queria
para vocês pem estas estrelinhas nas
vossas árvores e mas entretanto pronto
estou agora a ensinar já melhor e a
primeira coisa que vão ter que fazer e é
cortar faixas eu estou aqui a fazer com
2 cm S eu estou a fazer com 2 cm vou
precisar de duas faixas Se vocês fizerem
com 3 cm vão precisar de colar três
faixas e se fizerem com 4 cm tenho que
colar quatro faixas a partir daí eu já
não sei se funciona e pela mesma
progressão porque eu não fiz ok pessoal
Ah e depois de terem a faixa vão fazer
um pentágono vão estar assim devagarinho
numa das partes mesmo à margem e
deixando um dos lados só uma pequena
pontinha aí de 1 cm me mais ou menos
OK depois de ajustar tudo vão dobrar a
parte mais pequena para
dentro e agora o resto vai tudo muito
naturalmente como vocês podem ver
aqui vão enrolar devagarinho até ao
final
vejam aqui melhor o pentágono e para
engordar vão ter que apertar no meio dos
lados Ok com a unha devagarinho cada
parte e PR pessal chegamos ao fim eu
espero que tenham gostado e se vocês
gostaram inscrevam-se para acompanhar os
próximos vídeos e não não deixem nada
quer dizer este vídeo também tá assim
fora de tempo então é isso pessoal um
grande abraço e até à próxima tchau
tchau
m